My dad has sepsis close call, but back at home, tons way too many in my opinion of antibiotics, he has urinary tract infection, that he can't get rid of along with a catheter still.
He's been, it's been over a month now. What would you recommend from your clinic? Thanks so much, have a blessed day.
Okay, so a person with urinary tract infection, sepsis, that's an infection that's carried in the blood, that can be deadly, what do you do?
Okay, just, I mean, it's like, what's your protocol for this? Well, you got a dig to figure out what this is.
First of all, did they, did they test the blood? Did they do a culture? Did they find out what the infection was? Did they do a culture of a urine, a urine culture to see what the infection in the urinary tract is?
Because that's going to depend on how you would actually treat it. If he's been a ton of antibiotics, then maybe it's not a bacteria or it was the wrong antibiotic for the bacteria.
Or they didn't culture it. If I don't, what the bacteria is, if I don't, what the antibiotics should be.
Again, we see this all the time. I just had a conversation with gentlemen that had blood work done in May or in March, had elevated white blood cell count.
Definitely to the level where he had a corrected infection, elevated neutrophils, which would suggest most likely a bacterial infection.
And I didn't order the labs. His VA doctor did order those labs. Didn't do anything about it. Didn't tell him that there was an infection. Didn't tell him that we need to treat it.
And then went back in again at the end of April. They didn't even rerun the labs. I just don't get it. Why do you run the labs? If you don't do anything with them, especially when there's positive findings and you do nothing with them.
Why did you run the labs again? Or you put this person on some type of protocol and then you don't retest to see if you actually fixed it.
I'm sorry. I'm just at a loss for words. Here are these medical doctors. Have these multi billion dollar complexes where they can run CTs, MRIs, blood work at, you know, within a couple hours, get the results back.
And then they don't either don't read them. Don't know how to read them. Don't do anything with them. Don't retest.
I'm sorry. I'm a little frustration. Wagon here because I don't have those wonderful tools at my disposal where I could get blood work back within a couple hours and try to help the patient.
And they do and they don't do anything. So from a general nutritional standpoint, without no weed anymore data, I could help this person.
If a person has a urinary tract infection, that doesn't go away if they have an infection in their bladder.
One product that we use in our office is an herbal product called borosma complex because it has couch grass and it has licorice in it, has an echinacea in it, and butchew in it, which is really good for the urinary tract.
Another product would be de-mantles, which is a sugar, that actually is really good for UTIs.
I'm not telling you to take that, those would just be things that would be general recommendations with UTIs.